[Music]
my beard
it has been given
and taken
it has been watching
and now to support alzheimer's research
i present a chance to win genuine
trimmings of my beard encased in
glorious museum-quality acrylic
there will only ever be this one
for a chance to win it simply donate to
the alzheimer's association the more you
donate the more entries you'll get no
purchase necessary read the rules to
make sure you're eligible your chance to
win some of my beard hairs for a good
cause has arrived
gaze upon them admire them plant them at
the scene of a crime and send me to
prison for life what you do with them
should they become yours
is up to you
and as always
thanks for donating
you